INSTRUCTOR: Hi,
DATA 2100 students.
We are going to look at if
and input in Python today.
So Python allows us to input
something via the keyboard,
meaning allows the user to input
something via the keyboard.
The general form is we have some
variable that we're declaring,
and then we set that
variable equal to the input
of whatever the user enters.
So we use this input
function, and then we
place within that what we
want the user to respond to.
So if we want to say,
what is your name?
Is-- dot dot dot-- your name?
Then we would place that
within those quotation marks.
The greater than
sign above indicates
where to type or
the angle bracket,
if you want to call it that.
This is not required.
It's just good practice.
The example, x is equal to input
who's your favorite economist?
Then, they're going
to respond to that.
All inputs are
strings to Python.
I want you to write that
down, highlight it, whatever
you got to do to remember that
all inputs are interpreted
as strings to Python.
So if you need to be-- if
you need it to be a number,
convert it.
So for example, y is
equal to the value
of whatever the user inputs.
And then we change the value
of y to be that integer value.
So we say, once we have
captured that user input,
then we are going to use my
int function to convert that y
variable to be an integer,
and assign it back
to be the value of y.
So we're just saying convert
the value of y to be an integer
and assign it back
to that value of y.
Sorry, convert the variable y to
be an integer, and then assign
it back to the variable of y.
So let's jump into then our
examples that I have for you.
If you click on that link
again or if and input examples,
click Copy to Drive.
That's going to
create a copy for you
to be placed in your drive.
And then make sure that you--
I rename mine.
I'm going to say
Sigurd underscore
so that I can keep track of it.
And again, those are all going
to be within your Google Colab
folder in your Google Drive.
So that'll be a nice
organization there for you.
So let's jump into
these examples here.
Well, we want to assign the
variable A the value of 143.536.
So these first few are going
to be a little bit review,
then we'll get into our input.
So I'm going to use good
technique here and write
some comments out
as we're beginning.
Hard to remember to put
comments, but make sure you do.
So I'm going to
declare the variable A.
I'm going to say that
A is equal to 143.56.
Then I want the
variable B. So I'm
going to say declare
the variable A
and B. And I want B to be equal
to the integer form value of A.
So I'm going to say B is
equal to integer of A.
So we are saying convert
the value in the variable A
to be an integer.
So I'm going to go
ahead and do that.
Then, I want to print
out the variables as well
as their values.
For example, x equal
to 10.7, with each
appearing on its own line.
Only use one print statement.
So hint, you can use
escape characters here.
So I'm going to say, print--
I'm going to use
my f-string here.
I'm going to say,
print f-string.
We are going to say grab the
variable A, then do a new line.
And then grab the value
from the variable of B.
But I'm not quite there
yet because I actually
want to say A is equal to the
value from the variable A.
And then B is equal to the
So again, I'm using f-strings.
These brackets-- what goes
inside that bracket is
the value-- is the variable's
name that I want to have--
the value from that
variable I want
to place into this print
statement once I run it.
So let's go ahead and run
this, and see what we get.
So we are getting there.
But now, it's starting to
be a little bit mad at me.
I need to use my backslash n.
Wrong slash.
Let me go ahead and run that.
Perfect.
Now, I can delete
back that B equal to,
and it's going to format it
just a little bit better.
You'll notice I have
a couple of spaces
here that I can get rid of.
And then when I run this, I can
see that A is equal to 143.56
and B is equal to 143.
So again, A is a float.
There's decimal points after it.
I then convert A
to be an integer,
and assign that integer value
to B. So A is still 143.56.
And I just-- for the
purpose of this program, we
say, but I want B to be the
value of the integer form of A.
Then, within my print
statement, use that f-string,
and I'm having that bracket
denote that this is a variable's
name, and I want to have the
value from that variable placed
here in this print statement.
Awesome.
Then I want to
write a program now
that assigns a variable
National Parks to be
equal to the value of your
favorite National Park.
Then I want to print out
an all uppercase version
of your favorite National
Park reference that variable,
then an all lowercase version
of your favorite number
of your favorite
National Park, and then
the number of characters in
your favorite National Park.
So this is a bit of a review
when it comes to printing.
And so let's go
here really quick.
So we're going to declare our
favorite National Park as--
declare our favorite
national variable--
National Park as a variable.
So I'm going to say National
Park equal to my favorite
personally is Yellowstone.
But you can do whatever
you would like here.
Now, once I run this, nothing's
going to output to me,
because I just declared
a variable here.
I can see that it
ran successfully,
but nothing else
really happened.
Now, I want to print an all
uppercase version of it,
so I'll print National
Park, and this time I'm
going to use my upper method.
And methods just require that
we have an open and a closing
parentheses after it so we can
force the value of Yellowstone
to be all uppercase.
So now, when I run
this, I can see
that my all uppercase
value of the value
from the variable National
Park is printing to me.
So print all uppercase.
Then I want to print all
lowercase and you guessed it,
we're going to say
National Park dot lower.
Perfect.
And then I want to print
the number of characters
in your favorite National Park.
So let's use--
we're going to say
print the number of characters
in my National Park variable.
So let's go ahead and
figure out how to do this.
So the way that I
do this is I'm going
to harness my lean
command, which is basically
finds the links.
So I'm going to say print, and
I can say print National Park.
And that's just going to print
out the value of National Park
here for me.
But instead of actually
just printing National Park,
I actually want to print the
length of that National Park's
values.
So for example here, if I say
print Len of National Park,
it's going to go
in and it's going
to count the length of the
value of National Park.
So here Yellowstone is a
series number of characters.
So it's going to go in and count
those number of characters.
So we'll say 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11.
Yellowstone is 11 characters.
So now when I run this,
it's going to first,
the Len function is going to
be applied to National Park
and it's going to count
how many characters again,
the value of National Park is.
Then it's going to print
out that value of the length
of National Park to me.
So now when I run
this, I can see
that there are 11 characters in
Yellowstone which is my National
Park's variable's value.
Now, we are going to write
a program that asks the user
to enter their favorite number.
Here we go now.
We're into inputs.
Just a little brief review here.
Then we're going to return to
the user, their favorite number
divided by 3.
So let's go ahead and do
our first input command.
So I'm going to say fav num
is equal to whatever my user
inputs, let's say what
is your favorite number.
Again, this angle
bracket is not necessary.
You'll just see when this
input command is returned
to me that it looks nice.
So we can go ahead
and run this and we'll
see here, what is
your favorite number?
Then that angle bracket.
Then this little
text box appears.
And now I can interact
with my program.
And I can say my
favorite number is 6.
Hit Enter and then my program
ends, that check marks done.
My play icon is back and we
have now the fav num variable's
value is 6.
So let's go ahead and print
the fav nums variable value.
So it's going to run
this whole cell again.
So it's going to ask me to
enter my favorite number again.
So I'll say 6 again,
I press Enter.
And now print fav num
and it returns to me six.
But this time, I want
to return to the user
their favorite
number divided by 3.
So if I say print fav
user num divided by 3,
I'm just going to divide by 3.
I'll run this and
it's going to say
what is your favorite number.
I say six.
I hit Enter, and then
a type error comes up.
So it says unsupported
operand for string and int.
What?
That doesn't make any sense.
So let's come back here
and let's take a look.
I'm going to make a
comment here asking
for my user's favorite number.
Now, what did I tell
you about input?
Input is interpreted
as a string.
So here, this type error that's
coming back is saying, wait,
Reagan you are trying
to take fave num, which
is interpreted as a string.
Even though the value is 6,
it looks like an integer.
Input is always interpreted
to Python as a string.
So saying you're taking
six divided by 3.
So even if I highlight fave
num, as you can see here,
it shows me that fave
num is actually a string.
Can you see that?
And then within that 6, it
has those quotation marks
around it denoting that this or
those straight quotes around it
denoting that these are--
that this is actually a string.
So what I want to
do now, instead,
is I actually want
to say what fave num,
I want to convert
it to be an integer.
So what I'm going to
say is convert fave num
to be an integer.
So perform this integer
function on fave num,
then assign this value back
to be the value of fave num.
So I'm just changing
it to be an integer.
Now, when I run it, what
is your favorite number?
I say six.
I hit Enter and it
returns to me two
which is my users favorite
number divided by 3.
So that is how we go about
doing this program when it comes
to working with users input.
I can also do something that I
think is a little bit easier.
Instead of having the
second line of code here,
I can actually say
I want to convert
the input all within this
same one line of code.
Ask for user's input first.
This is going to run first,
then convert their input
to be an integer.
Now I run this, I say 6, I hit
Enter and two returns to me.
Now, down here on
question number 4,
I want to write a program
that creates a login system.
So I want to first
ask the user to input
their username, then output to
the username or to the user.
Your username is blank.
So I'm going to
ask for username.
So I'll say username
equal to input.
What is your username?
Use my angle bracket there.
Then I want to output
username to user.
So then I'll say print your--
I'm going to use my f-string
here, your username is--
and then I want
to place the value
from the variable username.
So now, I'm going to
add in my colon there.
Now, let's run this.
It says, what is your username?
I'll say Reagan, Regs Sig.
Now, I'll run this.
Your username is Regs Sig.
So I'm inputting
something to my program
and it's outputting
something to me.
Now, finally, we're
going to harness
the power of if statements
on this last program.
So if statements-- when we
think about if statements,
how do we use them in real life?
So maybe it looks something
like if I wake up on time,
then I can go on a walk.
If I prepare ahead for what
meal I want to eat tonight,
then I'm not stressed about
what I'm having for dinner.
So there's lots of if statements
that we use all the time
in our daily lives
and we probably don't
think of them as if statements.
But we use them all the time in
programming to make decisions.
So an if statement is a
conditional statement.
If the condition is met, then
everything in the indented text
block happens.
I want you to think about that.
If a condition is met, then
everything in the indented text
block happens.
Indented text block.
So conditional
expressions, mathematical.
They can look like this,
text can look like this.
So if we think about--
if something is less than
or equal to something,
and we'll learn
that we have to say
double equal to when we do
a conditional expression
in Python.
We can also say something in
a series of values, not in,
but we can use all conditional
expressions when we
are working with if statements.
This is when these
handy flow chart symbols
of decisions come into play.
We have some condition
within this decision symbol.
If some condition
is true, do this.
If not, do this.
So this is what my if elif,
and else blocks look like.
So if some condition.
So for example, if your
x is greater than 5,
whatever the condition may
be, do that, do some actions,
if this condition
up here is true.
So everything indented
and beneath that
if, will run if that
condition is true.
However, if that is not
true, so if this is not true,
then my elif runs and
it says, all right,
so if the is not right then is
the elif true, If elif is true,
then all of these
actions will run.
If that's not true,
then it comes down here
to my second elif
and again, everything
indented and beneath it,
if this is true, will run.
Finally, if none
of these are true.
If none of those
conditions are true,
think of these a lot
like where statements.
Those conditional
expressions in SQL.
None of those are true.
Then my else block will run
and we'll say, all right,
actions if no previous
condition is true.
So there's some rules
here a little bit with if,
elif, and else.
You can have an if statement
with no elif or else.
You can also have an if
and else with no elif.
You can have an if and an elif.
But basically,
what I'm saying is
you must have an if before you
can use an elif or an else.
You can also embed additional
if and else within indentation
blocks.
Now, a friendly
reminder, especially,
as we jump into if
statements, that we
write a little bit
of code, we test
the code, we debug the code.
If my program is
complete, then I'm done.
If it's not, then we write
a little bit of code,
test the code, debug the code.
Don't write lines
and lines of code
and then be like, oh darn it,
I don't know if that's working
or not.
So let's come here
to program 5 We're
going to do something
similar as above.
Write a program
that's similar to 4,
but this time prompt the user
to enter at least a 6 character
username.
If the user name is
less than 6 characters,
tell the user of their error.
So I'm going to say, all right.
Ask the user's username.
So I'll say, input--
sorry.
Username is equal to input.
What is your username?
Then I'm going to practice
what I just was preaching.
Run your code often,
so we'll say Regs Sig.
Then if the username is
less than 6 characters
tell the user of their error.
Well, I need to probably,
amend my input question here,
if you will.
My prompt, because
I need to tell them
to enter at least a 6 username.
So I'll say what
is your username?
Usernames must be 6 characters.
So I don't like
how that's looking.
Let's say user names require
or must be 6 characters.
Then I'll say.
What is your username?
So now when I run
this, I'm going
to have a little
bit longer prompt.
Username must be 6 characters.
What is your name?
Username.
I'm just going to
say random stuff.
And I'll hit Enter and--
that all I'm asking for right
now, It's just inputting this.
Now, I want to say
if the username is
less than 6 characters, tell
the user of their error.
So I want to evaluate here.
I want to say if the username is
less than 6 characters, do this.
So I'll say if--
and then how do
I figure out what
is the length of a variable?
Write that variable's value.
What is the length?
So I'm going to use
again my Len function,
that we talked about up above.
I'm going to say what is
the length of my username.
So if the length of my
username is less than 6,
so if this condition is
true that I'm setting here,
if the length of my username
is less of the username,
my user inputs is
less than 6, then
you'll notice that there is
that indent and I can say print,
it'll automatically indent you
entered too short of a your--
I'll say your username must
be at least 6 characters.
So I'm going to tell
that my user their error.
So let's try this out.
So I'm going to say,
what is your username?
I'm just going to do
two characters for now.
I hit Enter.
And it says error.
Your username must be
at least 6 characters,
So it evaluated what
I entered as the user.
And it said the length of
that username is less than 6.
So we're going to
print this error.
Everything indented and
beneath it's then going to run.
But if this is not true at this
point, what if I say my username
is a lot of Characters
and I hit Enter, well, now
my program just ends.
Because I never
told it what to do.
So an error did not happen.
My program just ended
because this was not true.
So this print command never ran,
which it shouldn't have ran,
because this was not true.
So then what I want to add
in here is an else statement.
Or else block that
says print, Thank you
for entering at least
a 6 character username.
Now, I run this.
Let's enter again my
two character username.
I press Enter, it says error.
Your username must be
at least 6 characters.
Let's run it again.
And now let's say I want to
have a really long username.
So now I hit Enter.
And it says, Thank you for
entering at least a 6 character
username.
So this is what you're going to
be doing here with if and else.
If this is true, then
run whatever is indented
and beneath it.
If it's not right,
then print, whatever
is contained within my else box.
I can have an elif here,
if I would like and set
some other condition.
But for now, that's where
we're going to stop here
in our if and input examples
just to get you acquainted
with if an input and then we'll
do more problems like this.
Take care, everybody.
Thanks for your hard work.